ich finde dass die FDP hier tatsächlich
eine komplette Irreführung der
Wählerinnen und Wähler betreiben mit
diesem Begriff Wasserstoff ready denn
unter diesen vermeintlichen Begriff der
technologieoffenheit wird hier
suggeriert man könnte sich Gasheizung
einbauen und die werden dann irgendwann
vielleicht von Zauberkraft Wasserstoff
ready sein und dann kommt dieser
Wasserstoff aber ich muss jetzt mal
sagen Irreführung finde ich jetzt schon
sehr harten begriff was steht denn oder
was wird im Gebäude Energiegesetz stehen
da steht ja nicht drin du musst dir eine
Wasserstoff bei die Heizung einbauen
sondern deine Kommune wird eine
wärmeplanung machen und je nachdem wie
die wärmeplanung aussieht wirst du dich
dann entscheiden können welche Heizung
für dich das Beste ist und das ist auch
der richtige Weg ist zu tun und die
Option dass wir auch Wasserstoff dort
einsetzen die sollten wir nicht aufgeben
[Musik]